[Music]
I believe that this nation should commit
itself to achieving the goal before this
decade is out of landing a man on the
moon and returning him safely to the
earth
they just had the courage to do what
they had to do and get the job done and
that's how we should try and live our
lives every day as a people 3500 been
burning Apollo 11 when they went to the
moon it was just a first for mankind it
takes a lot of people to make something
miraculous happened us so much knowing
that we can go for it knowing that we
can learn this much more about things
that we nothing about
[Music]
I have to say I was not a little kid
growing up on a farm in Michigan that
looked at the sky and said I'm gonna go
to the moon something I never never
thought that was a possibility but when
the option came to apply for the
astronaut program I knew that I didn't
meet the test pilot trained requirement
but I thought maybe it's a good idea to
apply anyway to see what see what
happens only 24 guys got to go but those
guys never would have made it if hadn't
been for the thousands of others behind
him when people asked me what that
experience was like I reached back to
Middle Ages times when the big project
that everybody could see might have been
building say the Cathedral its chart it
was this an enormous thing that the
whole community was behind and thousands
of people of various skills working on
this huge project which was rising out
of the fields that could be seen as far
as the horizon
we were called by the spacecraft
contractor and he said understand
there's going to be a computer in here
it is how big is it we looked around we
saw this electronic stuff what should we
tell him I said well it's amazing what a
cubic foot so that became the design
principle that you had to build a
computer that would do the job but would
fit inside the space of a cubic foot we
didn't have computer monitors or
anything of that sort whatsoever we
basically dealt with paper and that's
why we stared out when we were trying to
think about the software in the mission
so you knew that the answer was in there
if you had a riddle to solve and you had
to find it but you knew it was in there
it taught us to approach a plan with
continuity and flexibility it inspired
the world I almost looked back and and
seemed a little naive at the time we
were pioneering and it was exciting as
hell to be a part of whatever it was
Apolo hit me and most people very deeply
emotionally
[Music]
but it also had a very pragmatic city if
we set a very precise well understood
gold
that huge Gucci
what gold could be more Universal than
saying I see that thing up there I'd
like to grasp it I'd like to get my
boots dirty on it to me
the legacy Apollo has nothing new for me
oh I see of Apollo is that we can do
anything we want to from pretty much
we face problems now that are harder
than since then follow because sometimes
there's a lot of uncertainty about what
the problem actually is throw up your
hands and you say global warming what
can we do about it it's too far gone
when we talk about ending hunger what
would that mean I mean what what is the
requirement how do you know if you've
done it I think to say that we need an
Apollo like program for solving the
issues of say energy in the environment
is to say that we need a coordinated
effort that drives energies in a very
particular direction it will consist of
many many Apollo like efforts in many
different areas to finally solve this
challenge in that speech President
Kennedy also said we choose to do these
things not because they are easy because
that goal will serve to organize and
measure the best of our energies and
skills because that challenge is one
that we are willing to accept one we are
unwilling to postpone and one we intend
to win we need that kind of thinking
that kind
again
there's a real need worldwide to educate
a generation that can come and meet
these grand challenges developing a
technology just sort of for research
sake is sort of not enough you really
need to take that idea and allow it to
improve people's lives this generation
coming on now
enormous opportunities if we put our
faith in the mind absolutely confident
that
all placed
[Music]
one of the interesting things about
Apollo is the idea that we were able to
do something really fantastic in the 60s
that we're not exactly able to do today
and people in my generation I really
feel that that should be corrected that
we shouldn't have gone backwards I'd
like to see people living on that'd be
so cool it's a whole new world out there
and discipline to actually set up and
live there and like have a regular
lifestyle like on earth that would be
that would be incredible beyond our
solar system we don't really know what
it's like out there we don't know if
there's another planet like ours we
don't know if there's really life out
there whatever kind of life it might be
the giant leap that we should be making
now is not do we send humans back to the
but how do we send we're gonna move on
to the next challenge which is to go
back to the mode and it's not to go
there and touch the moon like we did
before but this time we're going to go
to the moon with the intent of staying
going to the moon
is what my parents generation did what
we should do again but it's really
saying how do we go beyond that time's
a-wasting
I think we've been marking time a little
bit in low-earth orbit the objective is
to get to the surface of Mars in in a
stepping-stone way one of the lasting
contributions of Apollo I think was that
picture that was sent back that
Christmas Eve of Earth rise over the
horizon there was this blue planet with
white clouds looking very fragile
[Music]
let there be light new there one line
by standing outside of the earth and
looking back we learn new things those
first pictures coming back from Apollo
really drove Earth Day and the
environmental movement knowledge is
power
knowing certain things can help you to
go on to learn even more things and it's
just a never-ending chain of learning
and just collecting this information and
intellect that is just so my challenge
to all of us is how do we take that
spirit of Apollo that excitement we felt
during Apollo and now have that same
excitement that same spirit to keep us
moving forward to solve problems we
don't even know about today
[Applause]
[Music]
it's my pleasure to welcome all of you
and to open this symposium on behalf of
MIT the School of Engineering the
Department of aeronautics and
Astronautics our faculty staff and
students and our sponsors
Charles stark Draper laboratory Lockheed
Martin orbital sciences corporation and
the Boeing Company the video that we
just saw captured many of the themes of
this event but I'd like to open by
providing a little bit more context for
the discussions that we've planned for
today and more context for some of the
events that have happened over the last
several months the spring and events
that will continue after these events
end today behind me is an image of a
telegram that represents a special
milestone for MIT and it's printed in
the program guide so that you can read
it for yourself it was sent on August
9th 1961 shortly after President
Kennedy's famous speech that we saw a
bit of it was sent to the person who at
the time held my position as head of the
Department of aeronautics and
Astronautics I was Charles stark Draper
also known by most people as doc Draper
the telegram announces that MIT has been
selected as the first team member for
Apollo and that we're given the
challenging task of designing the
guidance control and computer systems
that will get us from earth to the moon
we were given four million dollars for
the first year in today's dollars that's
equivalent of about 30 million dollars
so it was a very sizable sum however
this wasn't the start of mi t--'s
relationship with Apollo it was only an
important milestone at that same time
former student and professor Robert
Siemens
who we had a commemoration of yesterday
was serving as NASA's deputy
administrator and there were many other
activities that we'll hear about today
that led up to that point and we will
also hear today about what happened
after this milestone and our connection
to Apollo was extensive and it included
educating 12 of the Apollo astronauts
including four of those who walked on
the surface of the Moon given MIT is
very special relationship to Apollo
we saw the coming anniversary of the
40th 40th anniversary of the lunar
landing as a great occasion to look back
on the history of Apollo and to try and
extract lessons from that as we look
forward to future challenges in
aerospace and the visual metaphor that
we adopted for that here is the earth
rise image from Apollo 8 taken by Bill
Anders that we just heard discussed in
the video as well and we use this as a
visual metaphor along with the idea that
perspective was everything and I think
we all understand that when the world
vicariously stood on the moon and looked
back at the earth and out to the heavens
our perspectives of all three of those
things changed and likewise we hope
today
as we look back on history and we stand
here today and we then look out to the
future that our perspectives will change
and we've sought to extend the metaphor
yet further for aerospace not only
looking out at the future of aerospace
exploration but also looking at earth
and air transportation and some of the
challenges of energy and environment and
the role that aerospace plays in
connecting our world and in providing
Earth's sensing to better understand our
world finally one of the greatest and
perhaps the greatest outcome of Apollo
was the role that it had in inspiring
people not just engineers and scientists
but all people around the world
and we sought today to look back on the
leaders of Apollo and to share with
luminaries of today and who we hope will
be our future leaders many of the
students here at MIT this inspiration so
throughout the spring there have been a
series of events we started with a women
in aerospace symposium where we brought
some top doctoral students to MIT to
exchange views about their research and
interact with one another and others and
that was jointly hosted with a
Department of Earth atmospheric and
Planetary Sciences as part of that we
had a bond brill who's a pioneer in
space propulsion of 60 years in the
industry and she presented our Lester D
Gardner lecture we hosted a Sally Ride
for the Cambridge Science Festival and
had a thousand middle-school kids come
and interact with faculty staff and
students at MIT to get engaged in
engineering and science activities and
we also hosted an aerospace program in
the Saturday engineering enrichment and
discovery Academy which is run out of
our School of Engineering outreach
office and that's for Cambridge and
Boston area high schools and yesterday
of course we had the special
commemoration of Bob Siemens I'm
tomorrow we have opportunities for lab
tours and research to look at some of
the great things happening now at MIT
and there's posters and demonstrations
set up in the reception area finally
we've teamed with the MIT Museum and the
Boston Museum of Science and developed a
set of traveling exhibitions which will
go and be moved around to high schools
long after this event ends so there's
been a series of events of which this is
the main piece I'd like now to turn to
today's agenda we'll begin the morning
with a look back at Apollo um
through the eyes and words of those who
made it a reality then in the afternoon
we'll focus on the future of air
transportation and space exploration and
finally tonight we have a wonderful
celebration at Symphony Hall produced by
Keith Lockhart and the Boston Pops and
it is standing room only it should be
a very great show and I look forward to
seeing you there the image I'd like to
leave you with is a little bit different
and that's this one Apollo has inspired
many people in many different ways one
of the ways that inspirations expressed
at MIT is through a tradition of what we
call hacks where interesting things are
staged by unnamed students in the dark
of night and because of its prominence
the great dome features frequently in
those hacks and also because accessing
the roof at night and installing a large
piece of equipment involves some degree
of engineering an organizational
challenge these are regarded with a
sense of pride by many at MIT and this
picture shows a recent hack that was put
on the dome two weeks ago again by some
unnamed students and it's some evidence
of the continuing and lasting impact and
the excitement that our students and
faculty and staff still hold for Apollo
and it's with this MIT tradition that
I'm pleased to introduce our president
Susan Hockfield
[Applause]
Thank You Ian for a stirring
introduction to today's events but I
want to thank en and his colleagues most
emphatically for their genius and
bringing us all together to celebrate a
marvelous achievement of human discovery
and invention I want to welcome this
wonderful crowd of Apollo fans to MIT
and I want to offer special thanks to
our remarkable array of speakers some of
you have traveled very great distances
to join us and each of you participating
today adds a deep personal resonance to
the importance of the events we're here
to celebrate in acknowledged our
generous sponsors but I want to add my
own personal and institutional thank you
to Jim Shields and all of our colleagues
at the Draper lab doc Draper as most of
you know stands in the very first rank
of MIT legends along with the MIT
instrumentation lab that he founded
since his lab spun out from MIT in the
early 1970s as the Draper laboratory MIT
and the Draper lab have remained deeply
linked in spirit through a shared
commitment to first-class engineering to
national service and to educating the
next generation of pioneering engineers
the Draper labs support for education
takes a whole host of forms but not
least among them is their sponsorship of
50 fellowships a year which fund
graduate students enrolled in MIT
programs and as many of you understand
graduate students play the important
binding function they carry information
and insights between labs and they knit
the cross institutional collaborations
that are so critical for innovation for
all that and more thank you to Jim and
the Draper lab ian introduced the idea
that perspective is everything so let me
talk about what the Apollo program means
from our perspective here at MIT in fact
and in spirit the Apollo program
expresses exactly what we do here
discovery and invention the ambition to
reach the moon and beyond reflects the
same impulse that has driven every
scientist since the beginning of time
the drive for discovery through
exploration same force that inspires all
of us inspires a powerhouse like
Professor Maria Zuber in her own quest
to reveal the secrets embedded in the
moon's gravitational fields the
intellectual rocket of discovery is
powered by disciplined human curiosity
getting to the moon married the ambition
of discovery with the pinnacle of
invention the capacity of human minds to
define a problem design a solution and
using the great lever of Engineering
irrevocably shift the definition of
impossible for those of a certain
generation the moon landing completed a
suspense filled saga that began more
than a decade before when I took on the
presidency of MIT I said at the time
that I got here by way of Sputnik I
expect to others here may also go their
lifelong interest in science and
engineering to that first little
satellite I was six years old at the
launch of Sputnik 1 and I to this day
vividly remember the thrill of it not
the threat of Soviet supremacy but the
excitement of knowing that through sheer
hard work and ingenuity human beings
would one day get to the moon as we all
know
Sputnik revolutionized American
attitudes about science and engineering
the nation decided that it needed more
scientists and engineers and the
National Defense Education Act was born
a massive commitment to expand science
and engineering education and we needed
NASA and the Apollo program and those
commitments inspired a generation of
students who embraced mathematics and
in science who raced to MIT and other
schools where they prepared themselves
to do great things in service to the
nation and the world great things like
inventing the route to the moon and
beyond
now I'm hardly the first to suggest that
America could use a galvanizing cause
like the race to the moon today the
intertwined crises of energy and the
environment represent the defining
challenges of this generation challenges
that could offer a powerful impetus to
action and I believe that they must but
it's important to acknowledge some of
the many ways that the combined
challenges of rapidly increasing energy
demand energy security environmental
degradation and climate change do not
resemble the Apollo mission while the
moon landing was an engineering problem
with clear boundaries today's challenges
seem literally boundless and extend far
beyond engineering into the less
clear-cut universe of policy and
politics
Apollo relied on a tight team of experts
today's challenges involve changing the
behavior of billions of human beings at
President Kennedy's behest we would
accomplish the mission to put people on
the moon within a decade and we would
recognize with certainty when it
succeeded but no matter how brilliantly
we address today's challenges they will
last for the rest of our lives and
beyond
clearly the boundaries today's problems
are different and daunting yet their
potential to inspire is very real at MIT
we see it in many ways we see it in the
students behind our vehicle design
summit who United with their peers from
other universities around the planet to
design a car for the developing world
that gets 200 miles to the gallon we see
the spark of inspiration in the 1500
members of our student LED energy Club
which launched what is now one of the
country's premier conferences on energy
shoes and which I should point out was
started by one of our speakers today
David Danielson now the founding program
director of arpa-e and we see it in the
extraordinary inventiveness of our
faculty for advising everything from
novel battery materials and solar cells
to next generation nuclear power and
sustainable approaches to air
transportation I take great
encouragement from our new
administration in Washington and our
president's commitment to restore
science to its rightful place
he has already restored the office of
science advisor to the President to its
rightful stature and it's a great honor
to have John Holdren among our speakers
today an MIT aero-astro alumnus with
creative minds in high places the odds
of success increased dramatically
ultimately as a nation we all need to
see today's challenges not through the
dreary gray lens of impending
diminishment and compromise but rather
illuminated by the powerful beacon of
American ingenuity if we unleash the
same engine of innovation that took us
to the moon empowered the computer and
the biotech revolutions energy and its
environmental consequences could become
a driving force for economic growth and
a unifying national inspiration as
educators and scientists policymakers
and engineers we need to help more young
people see these problems as theirs and
to feel in these great challenges the
kind of inspiration my generation
experienced in the race to the moon the
kind of inspiration that made science
and engineering feel exciting and
important the made us believe that the
sky was no longer the limit the kind of
inspiration that will drive young people
today to reach for the Sun thank you for
joining us for giant leaps a celebration
of the Apollo mission to the moon and
beyond thank you
[Applause]
Thank You president Hockfield it's now
my pleasure to introduce Jim shields Jim
is the president and CEO of the Charles
stark Draper laboratory and is the host
for this morning's session reflecting on
the lessons of Apollo and as you heard
from Susan and we'll hear more from Jim
we have a shared history our department
in the Draper laboratories that started
back with Apollo and it's thus
particularly fitting that Jim is in this
role of host for this session so thank
you Jim Jim joined Draper labs in
night-in in 2001 and he's been president
and CEO there for the past three years
prior to that he was their vice
president for programs and prior to
joining Draper
he had a 28 year career at the analytic
Sciences Corporation he's an expert in
integrated multi sensor navigation
analysis weapon system performance
analysis and information management
systems development and logistics
management and I'm pleased to share that
he earned his graduate and undergraduate
degrees from our sister department in
electrical engineering and computer
science here at MIT welcome Jim
[Applause]
president Hockfield professor weights
distinguished panelists special guests
on behalf of Draper laboratory it's a
real pleasure to welcome you introduced
in the session that focuses on the
history and lessons of Apollo is
appropriate for Draper laboratory nmi
T's Aero and Astro Department to
collaborate on this symposium since as
Ian mentioned at the time of Apollo we
were the same organization the
laboratory was founded in the 1930s as
the instrumentation laboratory within
the department by the legendary
Professor Charles Stark doc Draper doc
is generally acknowledged as the father
of inertial navigation and he believed
that engineering education needed a
hands-on component and therefore he
established the contract research
instrumentation laboratory to provide
opportunities for students of the
department to see and work on real-world
problems so our shared commitment to
education is a long-standing one by the
time that the Apollo journey began
nearly 50 years ago doc MIT in the
instrumentation laboratory were well
established as the nation's thought
leader in guidance navigation and
control in early 1961 NASA turned to MIT
to determine if Wernher missions were
possible three months later President
Kennedy made his famous speech that we
just heard where he declared that this
nation should commit itself to achieving
the goal before this decade is out of
landing a man on the moon and returning
him safely to the earth
the first contract awarded by NASA for
the Apollo program was to the
instrumentation laboratory and Ian
showed you the telegram announcing that
to let you know how things have changed
this contract was only one page long a
situation we would never see today three
weeks into the contract in his first
meeting at the lab James Webb the NASA
Administrator wanted to know how long it
would take to develop the guidance
navigation and control system with his
usual aplomb Doc's enthusiastic reply
was you will have it when you need it
then to demonstrate his confidence that
the system would work doc volunteered to
fly on the first mission and run the
system himself doc was serious in a
recent letter to Bob seaman's he laid
out the rationale for why he should be
one of the first astronauts he would
know that GNC system inside now and
would be the best person to do the
in-flight troubleshooting and repair he
wrote quote if I am willing to hang my
life on our equipment the whole project
will surely have the strongest possible
motivation unquote of course it's
important to realize that doc was
already 60 years old and that nearly as
good a shape as the existing cadre of
NASA astronauts ultimately the
laboratory designed and built the
guidance system the flight computer and
wrote the software that took the lunar
module to the moon and back the GNC
system performed flawlessly and all
missions and there was not a single
failure in 1973 MIT divested the
instrumentation laboratory to create the
independent not-for-profit Draper
laboratory that was established do R&D
in the National International interest
by demonstrating first-of-a-kind
solutions to some of the countries
hardest technical problems including
defense intelligence space and today
bioengineering and energy Draper has
maintained an active role in space
playing a major role in every human
spaceflight program since Apollo we have
also continued the commitment to
advanced technical education that was
the reason for our creation Susan
mentioned the fact that we support
significant numbers of graduate
fellowships and we also support research
projects at leading universities Draper
fellows our graduate education program
take classes on a campus near to a
Draper facility and they do the thesis
research on a Draper project supervisor
jointly by a Draper staff member and an
academic advisor through these programs
the laboratory maintains a very close
working relationship with the Aero and
Astro department here at MIT over the
years the majority the Draper fellows
and much of the sponsored research has
been with the department this past year
17 Draper Fellow studied in the
department we have an exciting day ahead
of us so let's get into it
our first session entitled Apollo
reflections and lessons we will be
hearing from the luminaries who made
this important accomplishment
happen one of the speakers in this
session will be dick batten who was a
close associate of doc and he'll tell us
how MIT and the instrumentation
laboratory were in a position to be
awarded the first contract of the Apollo
program it's my pleasure to introduce
dr. Jeffrey Hoffman who will be the
moderator for this session dr. Hoffman
is professor of aerospace engineering at
MIT and a former NASA astronaut who has
made five space flights
becoming the first astronaut to log a
thousand hours of flight time aboard the
space shuttle Jeff was the payload
commander for STS 46 the first flight of
the u.s. Italian tethered satellite
system coordinating both the scientific
and operational teams working on this
project he's performed four spacewalks
including the first unplanned
contingency spacewalk in NASA's history
an STS 51 D in April 1985 and the
initial repair rescue mission for the
Hubble Space Telescope in December 1993
he worked for several years as the
astronaut office representative for
extra vehicular activity working on
tests of advanced high-pressure
spacesuit designs and of new tools and
procedures needed for the Assembly of
the International Space Station
dr. Hoffman spent four years as NASA's
European representative before during
joining the MIT faculty in 2001 where he
teaches courses on space operations and
Space Systems design he's also director
of the Massachusetts Space Grant
Alliance responsible for space statewide
space related educational activities
designed to increase public
understanding of space and to attract
students into aerospace careers I'd like
to invite Jeff and all our panelists to
come up to the stage and we'll get into
the session
[Applause]
well while everybody is taking their
seats and I believe mr. Sorenson is
going to be coming in I'll just give a
brief introduction as you all know this
afternoon we're going to be looking
ahead towards the future giant leaps
that face us but this morning is devoted
to looking back and celebrating the 40th
anniversary of Apollo and the role that
MIT played in this the way we've
organized the panel you you have the
listing of the panel members in
alphabetical order we've tried to
organize it thematically so that we will
start with Theodore Sorensen who saw
from the unique perspective of inside
the Kennedy administration how the US as
a nation
got involved in Apollo and then Richard
batten we'll talk about how MIT got
involved in Apollo after that we're
going to look at two of the critical
vehicles Nick you're next and then Aaron
and Joe Jack and Chris will look at two
of the critical vehicles with Aaron
Cohen and Joe Gavin who were responsible
for the developments of the command and
service module and the lunar module
respectively and then finally we will
look at the operations with Jack Schmidt
and Chris Kraft who have unique
perspectives of operations on the
surface of the Moon and of course the
surface of the earth in Mission Control
so that's the plan
Alex if you could help mr. Sorenson up
and while we're getting ready for mr.
Sorenson remark I just have two other
things a special word of thanks to
Professor David Mindell who founded and
heads our space policy group and he
played a critical role in the early
organization of this panel thank you
David
and then just a note to all of the
audience that there
will be an opportunity for questions and
answers after the break and what we're
gonna ask you to do in order to speed
things up is at the end of the first
session with everybody talking we will
be making available 4x6 cards and we'll
ask you to write out your questions hand
them in and then we'll organize the the
answers during the break which will take
place right outside I'm not going to
give extensive introductions because in
the interests of time we have all of the
biographies as you know printed in the
in the program so with that mr. Sorenson
will turn it over to you and thank you
very much for being with us oh thank you
thank you that's very kind I want to
thank everyone for being here I want to
also thank all those participating in
this program who participated in
America's exploration of space
what you did for our country and its
national security will remain paramount
for centuries to come in 1936 Franklin D
Roosevelt and his con race for
re-election he said in a speech
sometimes those who participate in
government ask whether it's worth the
cost and the answer is that what is most
important is this the biggest reward is
the sense of sharing and participating
in what is important to their generation
those of you in this program and
otherwise who participated in America's
space effort participated in something
of the utmost importance to our country
in our generation I am able to in the
old southern expression make a claim of
kinship at MIT and have that claim
recognized when I think of MIT
I think of Jerry Wiesner who was my very
close friend and colleague in the
Kennedy White House and whose
contribution to this country as well as
this Constitution is recognized by all
less known publicly who is the fact that
mi t--'s Paul Samuelson was a quiet
informal confidential advisor to
President Kennedy on the economy and met
frequently with the president and me
without those meetings being publicized
in the first year or more of the
administration that Department of
Economics also produced my son-in-law a
rising star in the economics the field
who I'm happy to tell you is going to be
here this fall as a visiting professor
and I urge you all to get to know him
Ben Jones is his name and he's a
wonderful human being as well as
economist I also was asked by MIT press
forty years ago or so to deliver a
series of lectures which I did give here
they were published by MIT press as a
book entitled Watchmen in the night
presidential accountability after
Watergate so for all those reasons I
have a special place in my heart for MIT
and I'm very proud to be here today very
lucky because I am NOT a scientist and
don't claim to have the expertise that
all those participating in this
conference will have but I did read some
years ago about a United States Senator
a lady who had agreed to give a speech
to the American Petroleum Association
for $50,000 and said that she would not
only provide the speech but for the
question and answer period she would
provide both the questions and the
answers
and I decided that was the system that I
could usefully employ and so I have if I
am able to read it provided my own
questions and I will provide those
questions and answers to you mr.
Sorenson
you can call me Ted number one why is it
that you as a non-scientist was selected
by President were selected by President
Kennedy to organize the response to the
yuri gagarin flight first Soviet
cosmonaut which was the opening round so
to speak in the global competition in
space which was part part of the
competition between the American and
Soviet systems in the Cold War at that
time why Sorensen knew was not a
scientist I think the answer to the
question is that the president relied
upon me in so many areas as a skeptic as
a questioner as a lawyer and Unitarian
who was raised asking questions and a
lot of questions had to be asked and
that was exactly the role I played two
days after the Gagarin flight when I
gathered in my office not many steps
down the hall and the West Wing from the
Oval Office I gathered the best experts
on that question in my office to see if
we could provide an answer number two
when do you consider the tens of
billions that were then spent ultimately
to send a man to the moon and to bring
him back safely to earth would not that
money have been
better spent to fight poverty or to
advance health and education and less
wrecked a cuter scientific projects in
this country the answer is perhaps that
money would have been better spent on
those other objectives but I do not
believe for a minute that in the context
of that time the height of the Cold War
competition with the Soviet Union the
Congress would have appropriated those
billions for health and education and
less dramatic scientific projects and it
was only because of the drama so to
speak of the lunar landing that the
president was able to galvanize and
unite a space effort that up to that
time had not only been lagging in
scientific accomplishment but had become
something of a joke with late night
television comics repeatedly showing
pictures of space us space Rockets after
a countdown fizzling or blowing up on
the launching pads so yes the money it
did cost an enormous amount of money but
I still believe that money was well
spent
number three it is often said that the
space race and the lunar landing in
particular were a matter of Cold War
competition with the Soviets and greater
prestige for the United States isn't is
not depress the
which sounds a little bit like face a
rather thin basis for such an enormous
effort and expenditure again one must
cast your mind back to that particular
time and the peculiar nature of that
particular national security challenge
the Soviet Union and its communist
allies around the world were intent not
only on expanding that every opportunity
their influence and their borders but
also winning the world especially the
so-called third world of new and
developing countries to their cause to
their banner whether in the United
Nations or in other councils of the
world and they believed that one way of
doing that was to demonstrate that they
had superior scientific technical
industrial and other means of
advancement and the Gagarin flight in
itself and President Kennedy knew that
and he sent a message of congratulations
the Soviet chairman Khrushchev the
Gagarin flight in itself was an
important point in convincing neutrals
and undecided leaders of the third world
that communists must communism must
really have something to it if it could
accomplish this marvelous feat and
Kennedy knew the United States had to
have an answer number four why did the
Kennedy team not reduce the cost and
risk by putting a robot on the moon
instead of a man that question was
raised at the time by Jerry Wiesner and
his Committee on Science and Technology
it was considered and the recommendation
was made that while every effort had to
be made to reduce the risk to the life
of the man or men sent to the moon that
nevertheless a human being is still the
greatest computer ever invented it has
powers of observation and judgment that
no robot containing a computer could
possibly match and I'm sorry that I
wasn't here for the presentation by Neil
Armstrong and others but I still think
that that is correct that the drama as
well as the findings of humans on the
moon were an important part of the
project and of Kennedy's accomplishment
number five when President Kennedy
declared his intentions to a joint
session of Congress what was the
Congressional reaction
I was about it
I was there in the house there was a
joint session and Congress reacted with
stunned disbelief and the president as a
good speaker can sensed that his
audience was not with him and it was the
only time in his presidency or major
career that I know about that he
deviated from the written text before
him and began to extemporaneously remind
the Congress that it had a major role
that it had to provide the money and the
authority and the support and he gave a
little riff which you will find in that
speech or in the films of that speech
where he said it's not just we're going
to put a man all of us will be on that
trip to the moon it's going to require
the participation and the work and the
support of all of us and he even talks a
little bit about contractors and labor
unions and educators and others must
take part and you and the Congress also
must muster do that part and that
initial disbelief in time gave way to
support from Congress which yes it waxed
and waned depending on how the program
was was doing but ultimately Congress
went along number six was this JFK's
greatest and proudest achievement terms
of permanent effect on America in the
world it probably it was as he said we
must sail on this ocean of space and
we will and we have ever since and we
will be forever after but whether it
ranked with the fact that his very cool
leadership in the Cuban Missile Crisis
which historians still called the 13
most dangerous days in the history of
mankind his leadership prevented the
world from being blown up or poisoned
into extinction that's a that was an
accomplishment which were it not for
that you and I wouldn't be here talking
about it today and the fact that he
declared on June 11 1963 to the entire
country by television that centuries of
discrimination and segregation on the
basis of race which treated black
Americans as second-class citizens were
to end and were to be prohibited by law
turned around after all those centuries
of America's principles I'm sorry to say
policies practices on race and surely
and moral terms that was an even greater
contribution to the role and history of
this country then then space and the
lunar landing as important as they were
number seven what would JFK think about
US activities in space today he of
course would be gratified that so much
has taken for granted and so much so
many direct and indirect benefits are
common today everybody has a cellphone
based on satellites everybody reads
weather reports based on
whole new meteorology equipment and
there are medical findings there are
transportation possibilities there are
the range of benefits from space are
enormous and he would find some
gratification in that but he would be
disturbed frankly that his plea from the
very beginning
that's space outer space be a presser a
preserve of peace is now being
endangered that the militarization of
space which was one of the very reasons
he set out to assure American mastery of
space was to prevent its military
occupation by the Soviet Union which
would have been a nightmare had the
Soviets been able to use their lead in
space exploration to not only colonize
but establish military bases in outer
space and the fact that the United
States has in the last decade talked
more and more of the military uses of
space I think would discourage him
greatly and he would be hoping to renew
that effort on space as an area of
scientific discovery and advancement not
for the US alone but to be shared with
others he wanted us to succeed in space
so in part that we could cooperate with
the Soviets in space their lead was
clear they dismissed his suggestion that
we explore space together because the
United States at the time had no
bargaining chips no cards on the
Abell no reason to pay any attention and
that changed only after the us space
effort began in serious as a result of
Kennedy's speech in April 1961 number
eight should the United States soon
return to the moon or go to the planets
I am NOT an expert today on either the
cost of such programs or our ability to
afford them given the trillion dollar
hit that the budget has taken as a
result of means to counter the collapse
of the economy in this country and all
over the world I do know that President
Kennedy felt comfortable in proceeding
with the space program in part because
we were at that time reducing
unemployment in this country
he was increasing the minimum wage for
those at the very bottom of the economic
ladder and he felt that such an
expenditure in terms of the national
interest would in time justify itself
and could be afforded and whether that
as possible today when wages are
stagnant and unemployment is rising and
the budget is deeply in the red makes
quite a different context number nine is
the Apollo model the best for some other
new massive project in space or science
again for the same reasons I would ask
is the Apollo model applicable today
bearing in mind that competition with
the Soviets identification of the space
effort as a national security priority
of the justification for bringing
together the most and the best of the
scientific and engineering talent in
this country on that one project because
of those national security implications
as well as the difference in the
economic context that I mentioned make
it unlikely that the the same approach
to a scientific project today would work
there has been some talk about returning
to the moon as well as exploration of
the planets there was an apocryphal
story that President Bush at one time
had said well that was nothing a Kennedy
going to the moon we're going to go to
the Sun and someone said to him mr.
president you can't do that the Sun is a
burning ball you can't land men on the
Sun and he said no we thought of that
we're going to go at night
but the number-10 this is uh this is not
my question but a question if you
haven't heard it you're going to hear it
because we heard it a lot if the United
States could put a man on the moon in
eight years why can it not solve world
poverty or cancer in four or why did my
plane from New York to make a forty four
minute trip yesterday sit on the run
away for forty four minutes before it
even took off
scientists are accustomed I am certain
two arguments by wrong analogy before it
was space it was the Manhattan Project
scientific genius collaborated at an
intense rate on the Manhattan Project to
produce the first breakthroughs on
nuclear weapons and I'm sure those
scientists who worked on that project
one of them happened to be a friend of
mine wearied of hearing for thereafter
well you did all that in a few years why
can't you solve problem X or problem Y
in a few years the answer is because
it's totally different because different
projects require different timetables
and in the political economic sphere the
Marshall Plan saved West European West
Europe from communism in the years after
World War two and in my time in
Washington in the early 1960s especially
we grew weary of people saying well
let's have another Marshall Plan do this
with the Marshall Plan wave
the Marshall Plan built the was did
deserves a lot of credit for the
recovery of West European countries but
there were they had democratic societies
free market economies a great deal of
infrastructure there on which to build
and to try to say that could be
replicated in far less positive parts of
the world was simply another miss
argument by a selection of the wrong
analogy in the early Roosevelt days my
father's hero George W Norris of
Nebraska was responsible for the TVA
which pulled together the natural
resource efforts of several south
eastern states and provided a rebirth of
agriculture urban development industrial
development and the economies in general
of what had been during the Depression a
very poor and broken-down part of the
country and again people would say well
let's have another TVA why not have a
TVA for India why not have a TVA for
Venezuela and saw again those arguments
simply miss apply one set of information
so those of you who are expert in the
space area are going to get it have to
become accustomed to hearing people ask
the question if the United States could
go to the moon in eight years of why
can't it solve some other massive
problem in that time are a lot less and
simply put up with those those questions
finally question a lot
what is for all of you in the audience
the next great giant step for global
breakthrough and which scientists can be
of help it might be in the space area it
might be in the medical area I hope it's
in the arms and political area in the
abolition of weapons of mass destruction
not only nuclear but biological chemical
and all the rest
it was the scientists of this country
who first recognized that the solution
of the splitting of the atom Unleashed
terrors even more than unleashing
constructive energy possibilities
it was the scientists who gathered at
Pugwash from many countries of the world
who recognized that man's development of
ways in which to live together
had to keep pace with and get ahead of
man's ability to destroy each other
that's what I hope all of you will be
engaged in thank you very much
the next speaker dick batten again the
biographies are in the program but I
just want to add one little thing which
is not in the program which i think is
very significant and that's that dick
batten taught his first class at MIT
which was a freshman mathematics class
back in 1946 63 years ago he taught his
the first time he taught the class which
he currently teaches which is
astrodynamics celestial mechanics was
1961 he is still teaching that course
it's one of the most popular courses in
our department the room is always packed
when he teaches it so in addition to all
the other accomplishments that you have
made I think that's absolutely
extraordinary so dick
he said it all I don't have to say
anything now I would like to talk a
little bit about how MIT got involved
with the Apollo program you have to
realize that in those days and probably
still today MIT was not allowed to bid
on any project they would could only do
things if they were asked to do them the
let's look back in 1957 these were not
luxurious accommodations for the MIT
instrumentation laboratory we had the
hood milk corporation and merged with
the put a more shoe polish factory and
that was and dr. IPERS offices up at the
top those railroad tracks are still
there I probably not the same tracks for
the same location across mass Avenue
then in that same year the Russians
launched their Sputnik on October 4th
1957 this is a a model of the split Nick
and it actually it used to until it all
wore out play the Soviet national anthem
and you press the button but it did
inspire the country to start to worry
about whether we're doing anything in
space those of us who were at the
laboratory at the time decided that we
could use some of the money from the
ballistic missile division of the United
States Air Force to fund the Mars
mission now how could we do that well we
we had a contract with the Air Force
that allowed us to spend a certain
percentage of that money on whatever it
was that we thought was
valuable thing to do so we decided that
we would build a spacecraft and here it
is we call it the Mars probe it was
going to be launched it had and then
passed by the planet Mars and then
returned to Earth now it has all of the
things you would expect to find on the
spacecraft has solar panels it has a
thruster to make velocity Corrections it
had an attitude control system with the
gyros so that you could move the
spacecraft and point it in the direction
that you wanted for that particular time
it had a sextant
for measuring making angle measurements
between lines of sight to planets and
the stars and it had a digital computer
none of these things of course had
really been done especially the digital
computer the the mission was a
round-trip mission from Earth to Mars
and as you can see it is a quite a long
trip this is the outbound portion and
then to come back you return to Earth
after an extra orbit of the Sun you had
to do that in order to keep the the
launch velocities something reasonable
so it was a more than a three year
program and the the flyby at the planet
Mars was certainly not a three
dimensional but it's not a
two-dimensional problem there's a three
dimensional problem and what you were
trying to do is to match up the outbound
and return velocities and you have to do
that
by a pass passed by of the planet Mars
now so here was the here was the mission
three year round trip the onboard
self-contained navigation that he
splashed down in the Gulf of Mexico and
the payload would be fished out it
actually had shark repellent on it so
that couldn't be accidentally swallowed
by a vermin and this was the model which
was on display now at the Draper
laboratory you can this this little
device we took it to Washington to try
to sell it to the new NASA and we got we
got to make to do some of the pieces
like we could work on the computer but
the rest of it was just in fact you know
when we when we were doing the flyby of
Mars
I felt uncomfortable I want to talk to
this Smithsonian astronomers and asked
them if they'd like to help and their
response was you really don't know what
you're talking about
they said you don't even know where Mars
is and and of course they were right and
it was it was off by about 20,000 miles
and in error but they didn't realize
that we were going to be navigating on
board and not navigating this thing from
from the earth we did make we did make
the press MIT project may solve the life
on Mars mystery
there are the guys that that worked on
it Milt ragga sir
Hal landing and they must younger me and
then the we realized that the computer
was the major problem how would we
design a small computer and its memory
in 1960 to survive a three year round
trip to Mars no data uplink no in-flight
service well that was the question
but then came 1961 a 1961 was the 100th
anniversary of them of MIT how many of
you do that it was also the 100th
anniversary of our Civil War and it was
also the 100th anniversary of Christine
shoe who was my grandmother so a lot of
important things were celebrated in 1961
Apollo the Greek god of light was really
America's program for orbital and lunar
landing operations I tried to get NASA
to to use that but I didn't make much
headway here it's also of course the
year of the challenge on May the fifth
Alan Shepard made his first flight then
20 days later President Kennedy on the
basis of that single little lob shot
decided that we were going to go to the
moon and 11 weeks later on August
as the tenth the MIT was awarded the
first NASA prime contract for Apollo
there's an interesting piece of
numerology 1961 has two prime factors 53
of 37 5 plus 3 is 8 that's for the month
of August and 3 plus 7 is 10 and that is
exactly when the contract was signed I
appreciate that because it was not it
did not come easy and I couldn't fudge
anything why was MIT chosen to do the
guidance navigation and control well
turns out that Jim Webb who is the NASA
Administrator was a good friend of dr.
IPERS he was not a any kind of an
engineer but he as he pointed out to us
he was very good at getting money out of
Congress and that was the important
thing for him to do and he would have
other people make political or make
mechanical decisions so here's the
here's the way the conversation with can
you develop the guidance and navigation
system for Apollo Jim Webb - dr. Draper
answer is yes when will it be ready when
you need it that's pretty good
scheduling and how do I know what will
work is if I will go along and operate
it for you was it
doc Draper's phone call with Jim Webb or
was it the Bob Chilton memo who is Bob
Chilton well let's take a look at what
he said
this he wrote a memo he bob-tailed with
the time was the head of the FIDE
dynamics branch of Langley field and in
he wrote a letter to the chief of the
flight systems division in 1960 November
7th and he was talking you can read that
for yourself I'll read it to you but
saying that the that the self-contained
navigation augmented by the MIT Mars
probe was just the kind of thing that
they needed of to put in play for the
Apollo spacecraft Apollo spacecraft had
to navigate itself it if it lost all
contact with the ground you could say
goodbye to it unless they could find
some way to come home and so it was very
important that we have that that
capability now Bob Chilton's memo is
kind of interesting it was stamped
confidential everything in those days
was was confidential
including the trade tables that I was
looking at they're stamped confidential
Bob gave me his original carbon copy of
this letter and imagine I were trying to
really be sending men to the moon and we
don't even know how to make copies of
things without making carbon copies well
why was the onboard navigation of basic
requirements for Apollo because the
Russians might not play fair they might
jam the communication lengths what
happened to the Mars probe well it never
flew but the
pewter work made it that the computer
for the Mars probe was the basis for the
Apollo guidance system probe here is
that here is that computer a photograph
of it not an artist's conception and it
is as the dimensions of about a cubic
foot and it weighs about 70 pounds
powered by what would take to put on a
60 watt bulb how many computers well
this is this is kind of interesting and
that is that why each for the command
module and for the lunar module and
remember there will be no in-flight
repair no built-in redundancy no uplink
from the ground many possible single
point failures but quality control
people could not calculate the mean time
between failures because the AGC never
had a failure it never failed in flight
you take it out of a box if it works it
will always work and I would like to
just emphasize what this thing was used
for there is Apollo 11 July 1969 there
are the people who flew it and those
photographs were taken not recently but
back in the in the early days the Apollo
11 crew and there's the emblem the eagle
and the little statements that said that
the eagle was has landed and I'll stop
there
well well Aaron cone is coming up I'll
just say one other little thing that is
not in the bio in 2005 we invited Aaron
to come and be a visiting professor here
at MIT and he and I led a we teach an
aircraft engineering systems engineering
course and somebody had made the
suggestion well the shuttle looks so
much like an airplane
maybe we should devote one semester to
studying the systems engineering of the
shuttle because in addition to being the
manager of the command and service
module Aaron was also the manager of the
space shuttle orbiter so Aaron called up
all of his subsystems manager most of
whom had retired living out in ranches
in West Texas or wherever
hey this is Aaron I've got one more job
for you on your subsystem we need you to
come to would you like to come to MIT
and talk to the students about what you
did how you designed it and the systems
engineering that was involved every
single subsystems manager that you
called plus Chris Craft of course but
you were not a subsistence manager you
you were in a special category but every
single one of them came and did it which
I think says a lot about the the respect
and and genuine affection that everybody
who's ever worked with Aaron still feels
so Aaron it's a delight to have you here
[Applause]
good morning I'm truly honored to be
here today sharing this platform with my
very good friends from the days of
Apollo and mr. Sorenson who served with
distinction during the Kennedy
administration where the story of Apollo
all began it is very appropriate in my
mind that this event marking the 40th
anniversary of the Apollo 11 lunar
landing and safe return of the crew be
held at MIT Apollo 11 did not just
happen many significant and
extraordinary contributions were made by
the women and men working at MIT as well
as the graduates of MIT and there's so
many it's hard to name them all but you
heard from dick battens graduated MIT
pretty soon you'll hear from Joe Gavin
who was responsible for the design
development of a lunar module was a
graduate of MIT and of course Brea's
Aldrin who received his PhD at MIT and
by the MIT instrumentation lab now known
as a Draper labs dr. Robert seaman's led
the way for Apollo and his great
abilities in engineering and management
carried the day for the program I
personally did not know dr. Siemens
during the early period of Apollo but in
later years I became associated with him
on national academy of engineering
panels and we had many discussions about
Apollo and the people of Apollo one of
those persons is dr. George Miller who
was a very close colleague of dr.
Siemens serving his head of the Apollo
program in Washington while dr. Siemens
was deputy administrator of NASA a key
program decision was made to test the
saturn v launch vehicle in an all up
configuration which charged strongly
advocated dr. von braun was very much
against testing and such in this manner
an argument ensued but in the end
George prevailed and this is a fact dr.
von Braun later told many people
that George had been correct and had
been not been for George's insistence
the Saturn would not have been ready in
time to meet the Apollo 11 deadline I
know for conversations with dr. Siemens
that he would want dr. Joe Shea to be
recognized as an outstanding systems
engineer and also as a outstanding
professor at MIT I would like to share
with you a little Apollo history
involving Joe Shea and myself while he
was serving as the Apollo program
manager at the Johnson Space Center
I had the position of assistant division
chief in the systems engineering
division Joe gave me a very important
task to define and resolve the
interfaces between all elements of the
Apollo program
this included the mechanical electrical
and functional interfaces between the
command and service module the lunar
module between these elements of the
launch vehicle and between all elements
in the launch complex he and I visited
each NASA Center as well as the
contractors at the Marshall Space Flight
Center he introduced me to dr. von Braun
and explained to dr. von Braun that I
was Aaron Cohen and I was going to
resolve all the interface control
documents called ICDs dr. von Braun said
he thought that was great but what was
an ICD I must say probably a lot of you
don't know what an ICD is but dr. Ron
didn't know what it was either and he
said I must say I must say that this
lack of knowledge or appreciation of the
importance of interfaces took me by
surprise one of my most cherished
documents for my years working on Apollo
as a memo written by Dave Howe AG of the
MIT instrumentation lab dated May 19
1965 in which he discusses my assignment
and saying that the MIT instrumentation
lab would support me in the fullest he
concluded his memo which was sent to 40
members of his staff he said I quote I
personally went to support Cowan to the
fullest please help him clean though
against tables referring to one of the
tasks
to Hercules in Greek mythology Dave ho
AG understood the importance of
interfaces especially in a complex
machine such as the Apollo spacecraft
with its many parts doc Draper was
already a legend in the field of
inertial gunner the nurse'll got
navigation and guidance and the
laboratory was already famous in
developing an ER shil navigation and
guidance systems their neural guidance
and navigation system is composed of an
inertial measurement unit an on-board
computer and in Apollo's case an optical
system program manager George Lowe said
and I quote if you had to single out one
subsystem being the most important most
complex yet most demanding in
performance and precision it would be
the guidance and navigation subsystem
and as you heard dr. Richard batten led
to this activity at Draper labs and told
you the efforts that went into the
design and development of the system and
I'm sure many of the people who worked
with dick are here today I would be
remiss if it does not take a moment to
pay my respects to my good friend Chris
Kraft Chris not only was the man who
developed the Mission Control at the
Johnson Space Center but also had the
managerial and technical insight to see
that the correct people were put in
charge of Dickel jobs and then allowed
them to solve their problems and do
their jobs the road to Apollo 11 was
marked by both tragedy and triumph after
several successful flights the program
was ready for an earth orbital man
flight termed Apollo 1 or Apollo
spacecraft 204 during a command and
service module test on the launch pad on
January 27 1967 there was a fire in the
cabin which resulted in the loss of
three crew members Gus Grissom Roger
Chaffee and Ed white after the after the
grief grieving and shock a very detailed
investigation concluded that the fire
was caused by the cabin environment of
16 pounds per square inch of 100% oxygen
a great deal of flammable materials and
undetermined again
sors I was named to a team headed by
astronaut Frank Borman which spent about
four months at North American Rockwell
in Downey California recently very
recently I had an opportunity to visit
with Frank and relive some of those
experiences we shared in the redesigned
activity there were many changes made to
the command service module to make it
more to make it more reliable and safer
the most important changes were to
eliminate the flammable materials but
also since we never could identify the
ignition source we took great care to
protect the wires from being damaged
thus avoiding a spark that could cause a
fire overall there were more than 100
changes made along with a major weight
reduction program on the command module
in order to make the command module
compatible with the way true limitations
of the parachute parachutes used for
landing one of the major changes involve
the cabin hatch and the cabin
environment originally Apollo had an
inward opening hatch but this was
changed to an outward opening hatch
during the redesign at the time of the
accident the inward opening hatch
required that the cabin pressure be
greater than the atmospheric pressure of
14.7 pounds per square inch
the command module had an atmosphere of
100% oxygen 16 at 16 pounds per square
inch at a hundred percent oxygen at 16
pounds per square inch
even stainless steel will burn as George
low then the program manager at the
Johnson Space Center commented as
incredible as it may be we have all been
blind to this potential problem
therefore it was mandatory that the
cabin environment be changed well out of
Downey I received a call from George
instructing me to form a team to solve
this problem a chart I chose a high
level engineer at North America named a
Levine a medical doctor and the
astronaut corps called Joker one named
Joe Kerwin and at Johnson Space Center
engineer named John Joe Carroll who by
the way was also a graduate of MIT
the results of our study determined that
the henceforth Apollo would fly in space
with a pure oxygen atmosphere at five
pounds per square inch but on the launch
pad the cabin atmosphere would be 60
percent oxygen and 40 percent nitrogen
at 16 pounds per square inch
this meant both the flammability and
physiological requirements
it took engineering and ingenuity to
change the cabin launch environment on
the pad to the cabin environment space
I'm very proud of the solution our team
developed to solve this critical problem
after the hiatus of 21 months since the
204 fire we were ready to fly again
Apollo 7 was launched as an earth
orbital mission on October 11th 1968 and
was very successful
the next event was a major triumph for
the Apollo program Apollo 8 was one of
the most exciting and bold adventures
that I personally experienced during my
years at NASA to leave the gravitational
field of Earth and travel to the moon
and perform a lunar orbital mission and
return to the earth safely was very bold
I'm sure that Chris Kraft I know the
Chris Kraft had a great deal to do with
flying this mission and I'm sure that he
will describe it to you my role in this
mission came from George Lowe again when
he asked me to form a very deal to
detailed comparison between spacecraft
106 which being which was being prepared
for Apollo 11 and spacecraft 103 which
be used for Apollo 8 pending approval I
remember taking my report dated August
13th 1968 to George Lowe at his home
late on the evening prior to his flying
to to Washington headquarters
headquarters in Washington so that he
could take with it with him to obtain
approval for the mission and as they say
the rest is history the missions of
Apollo 9 and 10 proved out all aspects
of the Apollo system and we were ready
for Apollo 11 the road to Apollo 11 was
now paved and the great adventure in
space would be undertaken when I look
back on Apollo 11 I go through each
subsystem and
marvel and just marvel how we managed to
perform the mission and to the young
people in the audience who are wondering
what to do to prepare themselves to work
on a program such a Paulo I say first
from my experience let me say you have
to be fortunate enough to find yourself
at the right place at the right time
when such a program was undertaken and
as dr. Siemens and many others have
stated so clearly and often the Apollo
program was such a success because it
well it did have complete support from
the public and from the president and
eventually from Congress this is very
difficult to achieve I think this may be
very difficult to achieve in the near
future for many different reasons but I
do leave the students with one challenge
the brilliant young minds at MIT should
work on why we need to go in to explore
outer space
dr. Harrison Schmitt our astronaut has
worked on the use of helium-3 for energy
I don't officer this is a solution but
things like this need to be explored to
see if we can find a useful purpose to
explore space and I think the brains of
the young students at MIT are good to do
that I would like to leave you with two
thoughts one is at the peak spending
year of the Apollo program which is what
which was in a nature of a race to the
moon the NASA budget amounted to a boy
about 0.8 percent of the gross national
product or about 3.8 for 5 percent of
the total federal budget the total
expenditure for the program was twenty
four point five billion dollars in 1970
dollars the experience also this
expenditure also cluded much of the
infrastructure that NASA has today such
as the Johnson Space Center the Marshall
Space Flight Center of the Kennedy Space
Center along with many test facilities
finally the next time we go to the moon
I think we will learn it's just how
difficult it was to perform Apollo 11
thank you very much
the next speaker is going to be Joe
Gavin who's whose baby was the lunar
module which is what which was the first
and and I guess is still the only human
space vehicle which never had to fly
through an atmosphere it was an
absolutely unique vehicle totally
critical to the sexist success of Apollo
and Joe we're looking forward to here
with the first I should tell you that in
my graduate year Bob Siemens was a newly
hired teaching assistant and I think
something started there and dark Draper
was my thesis adviser of course I didn't
see much of him because he was down in
the basement building gun sights for the
Navy well let me start by complimenting
John houbolt because he was the one who
advanced the idea of the lunar orbit
rendezvous which in my view was really
the basis for success in the whole
Apollo mission and one of the things
that got us a good position in the
competition for the lunar module
contract was the fact that a group at
Grumman under Tom Kelly had done a very
definitive study that in my view
absolutely proved the merit of lunar
orbit rendezvous and that's about all
I'm going to say about the missions
other than the fact that the lunar
module worked every time
I'll say that again it worked every time
particularly
in the improvisation and the
improvisation in Apollo 13 and what do
you didn't see on TV or maybe you did
see it on TV but you didn't see it in
the movie
and that was the long periods of time
when nothing was supposed to happen
and indeed we hoped nothing would happen
well let me talk a little bit about the
contract because it was a uniquely
conceived incentive fee contract and
allegedly there was trade-off space
between performance
schedule and cost well it didn't take us
long to figure out that it didn't quite
work that way that performance was
absolutely the first priority schedule
would come next and cost was the
derivative of the first two now this
this leads to what I consider a very
basic axiom which most bureaucrats and
politicians don't like to recognize and
that is that if you're going to do
something that's truly novel there isn't
anybody who can tell you how long it's
going to take how much it's going to
cost now that I think is one of the
basic truths certainly we had grown and
learned that now there were some other
problems in the beginning we had built
and we're building some airplanes for
the Navy that had rather complex
electronic systems in
but the airborne electronics of that era
just was not good enough but even worse
than that was the fact that we who had
grown up in the aircraft industry were
in the position of not being able to
flight test the vehicle before delivery
now this is a truly frightening
consequence of the way the Apollo
program is going to work and the fact
that the lunar module was never going to
act
operate in the atmosphere and this led
to the establishment of an
extraordinarily extensive ground testing
at five levels between the basic circuit
and the full vehicle and I'll give an
example of that and we learned several
things from that I'm not sure learned is
the right word because I cannot remember
when some of these things were vocalized
the first one was there's no such thing
as a random failure if indeed the design
has been done properly and the
environment is understood there has to
be a reason for the failure which you
can find and which you can fix and in
the course of the 10 years of Apollo we
recorded something over 14,000 anomalies
from various test programs from all the
test programs of those only 22 defined
analysis and in the case of those 22 we
changed some
thing anyhow
I mentioned that it was an extensive
test program in fact some things were
retested when later examination led us
to believe that we hadn't really
accomplished what we set out to do now
in the way that similarly in aircraft
we'd had a structural drop test after we
discovered how flexible the structure of
the lunar module was we wanted and we
finally convinced NASA that we should
drop tests and a lunar module that had
all systems fired up so that we can see
whether any of the circuits would be
interrupted by structural flexibility
well of course no circuits showed any
sign of difficulty but we didn't didn't
discover one minor structural thing it
probably would have made any difference
if we hadn't found it but at least there
was one tiny result from the test in
addition to the fact that it reassured
us another example that idea that was
derived was that one should take
absolutely nothing for granted and
there's an interesting example of that a
young engineer working on the instrument
panel said to himself one day we're
using these standard and toggle switches
which have been used for a long time in
aircraft and I don't really know what's
inside that case so he took about a
dozen to
the manufacturing floor had them opened
and interestingly enough in about a
third of them there was a little ball of
free solder now in 1g perhaps that
stayed at the bottom of the case but in
zero-g
who knows what it might have done to the
switching now we had to have a test
obviously to determine which of these
switches were good and which should be
discarded
and so we arranged to shake them at the
proper frequency and we discarded about
1/3 of the switches in stock
another axiom that we came across was do
not ever change anything that works for
at least a half a dozen years we had
been operating the glycol system in the
lab with amazing lack of difficulty but
some months prior to Apollo 11 a routine
check revealed that we had some flexible
crystals little needle-like crystals in
the glycol nobody had ever seen these
before and we thought well we'll filter
so we've set up some filters transfuse
the fluid out of the lamp through the
through the filters and back into it and
the more we filtered the more crystals
we found and time was getting short and
what we did I'll skip to the answer was
we made up some fluid that looked a
little bit like pulpy orange juice and
we Brown ran the ground test rig for two
successive missions and I went to the
three day before lunch meeting to clear
the vehicle was being ready for flight
with a number of I think there were five
small vials going from the clear fluid
to the stuff we had tested in the ground
rate and so Apollo 11 went to the moon
with not exactly orange juice but
something pretty close to it in the
fluid system and of course it worked
which was a great relief another thing
that was developed during the course of
this program and this was something that
evolved over some time was working very
intimately with our major subcontractors
now we had some major subcontractors
doing things that haven't been done the
descent engine that TRW had deeper
throttling than anything that had been
done prior to that the United
Technologies produced a backup system
for the MIT primary guidance based on
strapped down as opposed to gimballed
gyros and RCA came through with a
rendezvous radar that was I think the
first solid-state completely solid state
radar having brought up the
solid-state they should say that we were
limited by NASA and how far we could
apply that technology it was allowed
only when nothing else would do
consequently we built most of the
communication gear the old-fashioned way
little pieces all soldered together and
let me tell you we spent more hours
trying to get the yield up on those
components you wouldn't believe it and
in the course of this we had worked more
closely with the contractors than any of
the aircraft programs had been and we
worked at three levels engineer engineer
contract administrator to contract
administrator and executive to executive
because you had to have the same feeling
of motivation and schedule recognition
at the subcontractor as we did at the
prime well there are so many other
anecdotes that I could give of things
that we discovered along the way and
found that we had to do things
differently to get this machine which
would each one of which when launched
was brand new and never hot fired as a
vehicle and in closing I want to
recognize some of the people who worked
on the program and I'd like the first
slide first of my slides the only slide
now this is a plot of manpower versus
date and you don't have to read that it
goes from the beginning of the program
to the end there and one of the
interesting things is this slope right
here
we were under great pressure to get the
job moving faster because after all we
were starting a year behind the command
and service module and we discovered
that under those conditions you remember
these are the days of big IBM mainframes
none of the modern technology and
engineering design but we could add
people just about two hundred per month
and and have an efficient operation
engineers are really not a commodity
you've got to get the right person in
the right slot with the right group
leader and you hope that they're
compatible and sometimes this takes some
juggling but I think for there's
probably a similar slope in today's
engineering where you can't do better
than a certain number I would point out
that that notch at the top represents
the change in activity during the
recovery from the results of the fire in
the command module and I'd also point
out that this difference right here was
the amount of overtime that we worked
now NASA was always on our shoulders
because we had
too much overtime but this was something
that Grumman and had a lot of experience
in and I believe that we really had a
more efficient operation running over
time as we did but the point I would
make here is that we had a system where
the group leaders could take care of
their people in other words a group
leader could send a man home for a day
and this was very important because it
it gave the people who were under the
pressure to produce the feeling that the
company did care for their good health
and for their family problems a lot of
the people here were basically from
young families and as most of you will
remember young families have emergencies
and we did accommodate those from time
to time so the point here is that there
were some people who made major
contributions and a lot of people who
made very minor contributions but all of
those contributions were important now
we had a corps of engineering and shot
people technicians mechanics that I
thought of as the tried and true people
we had worked with the years and where
the word was absolutely acceptable that
is if somebody said something it was
understood and meant but we had a lot of
motivated recruits because we had to
build up very quickly
time for some of the recruits to figure
out how Grumman worked we did finally
produce a an organization shot which was
probably good for about three days and
looking back at it the thing that made
everything work it wasn't my idea was a
an early morning 7:30 in the morning
stand-up meeting where the leaders of
various groups came together and the
point was that if you were in trouble as
a group leader waiting on somebody else
this was the place to get some action it
was all done orally and we had some
people who kept track of the schedule
and the sequence of which things were
done but I really believe that that
stand-up meeting would cut down the
length of time that many things would
have taken well I could go on with many
other anecdotes but I think I've given
you some flavor of how we faced a truly
novel undertaking and managed to bumble
our way through it thank you
there's a lot of question about how to
do the bookkeeping but I'll just say
that Jack Schmidt was the last human
being to step down onto the surface of
the Moon I'll just relate one other
anecdote which I'm sure you've forgotten
many many years ago in 1978 when I was
in a new class of astronauts a lot of
the older astronauts were invited to
come and talk to us and and you came and
I think you were senator at the time at
78 right Oh as a matter of fact it was
okay so in any case your advice to us
was you're not going to be astronauts
forever pay some attention to what
you're gonna do afterwards and and there
we were new young recruits we couldn't
even imagine what it was like to fly in
space much less the fact that our
careers would someday have to go
elsewhere but after my fourth
spaceflight I remembered your words and
sure enough here I am at MIT so I just
want to thank you for your good advice
hearing what you have to say hey thank
you Jeff how often do people remember
advice you've given alleges it's it's
amazing it's a great pleasure to be with
you the audience the young people that
are here and certainly with my former
colleagues and I hope still colleagues
in various ways and and this is the
first opportunity I've had to I believe
meet mr. Sorenson and I enjoyed your
remarks extremely well it it really was
a pleasure to be here with you what I'm
going to do is very quickly maybe a
slight change of pace here is take you
through and I mean quickly the sequence
of events that go with an Apollo mission
this happens to be the Apollo 17 mission
but and apologies to Neil Armstrong and
Buzz Aldrin who are here that I don't
have the same set of pictures for their
mission but the Saturn 5 was the basis
of the success of our operating really
without it the heavy lift that it
provided we would not have been able to
do what we did and it was everything was
big
to Saturn 5 over 360 feet high and 6.8
million pounds fully fueled
seven-and-a-half million pounds of
thrust at liftoff and just to get in of
course the building that it came out of
fully constructed was at the time the
largest enclosed space in the world
since superseded I believe by the Mall
of America in Minneapolis and and if you
just to give you perspective in the
lower right there that red object is a
very large fire engine now launch people
often wonder what it was like and they
tend to forget that you don't reach the
full 4G loading that you do after two
hours and for 2 minutes and 45 seconds
and it's mainly a vibration experience
and I in order to have that experience I
recommend you drive your your pickup
truck if you have one f150 hopefully and
drive it over down a railroad track that
still has ties and that'll that'll give
you some perspective of the kind of
vibration that we were experiencing our
mission left 2 hours and 40 minutes late
because of a computer programming issue
and and so we accumulate a great deal of
florida ice frost if you will on the
side of our coal fuel tanks and oxidizer
tanks and you can see if you look
carefully you'll see some of that ice
coming off the side of the vehicle and
indeed most of it came off during this
very heavy vibration this picture of the
earth it was the first real opportunity
I had and any in the three of us had to
look back and see where what we had left
I took this from 34,000 miles away on me
of course the first day of our trip to
the moon the where we were headed
actually for Apollo 17 with this picture
was a this actually mostly this part of
it is the far side of the moon you don't
get to see that very often unless you're
doing some things as students you
shouldn't be doing
the valley of taurus-littrow is right
there this is the Sorento Titus basin
it's about 740 kilometers long Neil and
Buzz will recognize their landing area
right there and just over the horizon
would be where Apollo 16 landed the
valley of taurus-littrow about 50
kilometers long and about seven
kilometers wide that's the command
module Erin if you see it right there in
the middle of the picture
this picture taken from the left-hand
window of the famous lunar module that
worked every time
Thank You Jo and our landing point was
going to be right there this valley is
deeper than the Grand Canyon of the
Colorado this South Massif is 2,100
meters high the mountains over here get
up to just slightly less than that the
lunar module that worked every time is
shown here and I guess the most
important part of this picture is many
years ago I believe it was in Sydney
Australia a young man asked me why did
we put pizza on the landing gear and and
Joey that's a question I couldn't answer
and I had forgotten they were even Pizza
a well-dressed geologist astronaut and
including even a pilot astronaut if you
have to have them along is where's what
you see here the total earth weight of
this outfit plus the yours truly inside
was about 370 earth pounds but on the
moon with one-sixth gravity that's of
course only about 61 pounds and so that
made it very really quite easy to move
across the surface I was able to use a
cross-country skiing technique and was a
to get up to a easily six kilometers an
hour and if I needed to even faster than
that
just riding above the surface of course
not on it the pictures that you have
seen of Apollo we're taken with this
Hasselblad camera that you see mounted
on the chest here next time we go back I
surely hope that we have a smaller
camera than that
and the only difficulty we all really
had physical difficulty was working with
these gloves the forearm muscles get
tired quite quickly if you don't
discipline yourself and now Jeff and his
colleagues and working with the space
station construction have finally
learned that you can do a lot more
training with your forearms and we did
and that's going to be extremely
important along with hopefully some
bright young MIT student coming up with
a far better design glove than we have
even today the scientific side of the
mission our mission of course in the
last three missions was was the the real
Russell at era of going again and again
to the moon this is one of the large
boulders that we examine and actually
gave us an age date on the age of the
serrano taught us event and if you look
very carefully some of you may be able
to see the lunar module that worked
every time sitting there in that
light-colored spot just to the right of
the peak of the boulder at station six
these boulders some left Boulder tracks
as they roll down the mountain and here
you see the near edge of the track for
this large boulder and my footprints
going down into the track out of sight
up the other side the nice thing about
those footprints is they'll stay in
recognizable form for about a million
years not bad you know leave your leave
your footprints in the sands of time for
a million years might even be two
million years the only erosion that's
going on here are the impact of small
meteorites and they guardin stir up
about a centimeter or two of soil in
about that length of time again if you
want to leave your footprints in the
sands of time I strongly recommend the
moon
rather than Washington
returned for us was quite it was a
little more exciting maybe than normal
we had left the earth at 25,000 miles an
hour but in order to make up that 2
hours and 40 minutes that we sat on the
pad and to make sure the Navy was at the
right place to recover our spacecraft
are we got to the right where the Navy
was I guess there's a better way to put
it we had we had come back at 36,000
miles an hour into the atmosphere and
landed actually in the Pacific within
one minute of the planned landing time
Chris will remember that and really a
remarkable tribute along with our the
pinpoint landings of the last of all the
missions except for Apollo 11 and that's
a different story Chris may talk about
the navigation to the moon and in deep
space and clearly related to what dr.
afer and dick batten and the crew did
just was unbelievable I still think it
was magic but it worked and with the
lunar module it worked every time now
I'd like to finish up here with just
giving you my perspective of what the
keys to success of Apollo were and
actually this builds on something that
Neil and I began to discuss in 1975 and
this is my current list and I'm willing
to revise it in fact I've already had
some ideas on how to do it but to begin
of course with a sufficient base of
technology and that technology came from
a quarter from World War two the Cold
War activities going on and then some
very important decision that Dwight
Eisenhower made not only with the
creation of NASA and and and the early
development of the technology for
weather satellites and communication
satellites but in January 1960 he
specifically and personally wrote T
Keith Glennon the administrator of NASA
and told him to get started on a super
booster which became the saturn v
Eisenhower also insisted and finally was
able to get the army to move on Browns
group over into NASA so though that
groundwork those foundations really have
made it possible for there to be a
credible challenge to a generation to
land on the moon before the end of the
decade of the 60s the reservoir of young
engineers and skilled workers has to be
as critical if not more critical than
any other component the average age of
the vast majority of Joe Gavin's
employees of the employees in NASA was
between 20 and 30 years old and you've
got to remember that it's just
absolutely critical to have the stamina
imagination motivation and that comes
with young people and if your agency has
an average age as NASA does today of
about 50 years you probably are starting
out with a problem
and you need to figure out how to fix
that the art of course was the Sputnik
generation that has already been
discussed and and by the way Homer
Hickam book is one that if you haven't
read it October Skies originally titled
rocket voice is a very important
contribution to that understanding there
was at the time a pervasive environment
of national unease in part because of
the campaign of 1960 as Ted will
remember the missile gap was a part of
that campaign and and probably there was
not as much of a missile gap as people
thought there was because the individual
services were indeed dealing with the
the needs of their their special needs
for the delivery of weapons by ballistic
missiles but nevertheless the unease
existed there was a catalytic event
building on a Sputnik of course of
Gagarin's flight that brought focus and
we had an articulate and trusted force
why see president and John F Kennedy to
articulate the goal there were also very
importantly adequate reserves management
reserves
funding the the story goes and I think
it's largely correct that and I've seen
some of the numbers that the Georges
Lowell and others and at headquarters at
the time were estimating that the the
cost of actually landing on the moon not
the subsequent cost of continuing the
flights would be somewhere around the
average was probably around eight
billion dollars and and the Jim Webb
said well we're going to double that and
that's what he asked for and so we
basically had a management reserve of a
hundred percent now you can't you'll
never get that today you can't get any
management serve to speak of today but
it is extraordinary critical to reduce
program risk and human risk in any kind
of complex program of this kind and the
OMB in Congress of course are key to to
ensuring that that reserve would be
there and you need a culture of Liberty
as we had in the United States at the
time and hopefully will continue to have
that allowed tough and competent and
disciplined management to let people do
their job and that's already been
mentioned by Aaron and and and that's
extraordinarily important these young
people can do the job if you give them
the framework in which that job can be
done and the flexibility to get it done
and that all really came into focus most
of it was already there prior to the
2:04 fire that has been mentioned but it
really started to be focused after that
fire and and we had the right system in
place to make Apollo 11 successful and
and I would just add at the final thing
that deep space operations still require
these keys to success the legacy of
course for Apollo is in many different
forms the Cold War political goals of
Eisenhower and Kennedy were met Soviet
Union leadership was clearly intimidated
if you've ever talked to Emma Grace
about it and that made the Strategic
Defense Initiative of Ronald Reagan more
credible to them than maybe even was to
people in the United States the and us
pride and confidence was enhanced and
those of us all of us who travel the
world after our mission
found that other peoples were
extraordinarily encouraged by their
future now did we follow up on that as
we should probably not but at the time
that had happened and it is a legacy
that could be reinforced in the future
the cultural legacy there was certainly
a new evolutionary status of the human
species in in the solar system we now
know that we can live on the moon and
almost certainly on Mars as well the
resources are there for the for humans
to live independently the earth once
established a rapid improvement of the
human condition on earth came with the
acceleration of technological expansion
we develop future terrestrial energy and
environmental improvements the NASA was
one way to look at going to the moon or
going into space is it's a exercise in
the conversion of energy from one form
to another and believe me we learned how
to convert energy from one form to
another and that technology permeates
our the world's society today and we
also as Aaron has mentioned discovered a
resource a potential resource on the
moon helium-3 that may well satisfy some
not all but some of the Earth's needs
for electrical power some in the future
space settlement resources also were
identified we tend to forget about that
but the hydrogen oxygen water and food
that can be produced on the moon gives
us the flexibility for future act
activities in space without the cost of
lifting those resources from the gravity
well that we call the earth with a
scientific legacy a first order
understanding of the origin evolution of
the moon that understanding really
relates directly to the early history
the earth in that period of time in the
first seven eight hundred million years
of Earth history when life was beginning
on this planet and our insights are far
more robust than they were previously
about the environment in which that life
had to evolve there was the course with
the understanding this first order
understanding the moon we have the basis
for comparative planetology that is the
comparison with the other planets the
true
planets in particular we and in that is
a record of the history of the inner
solar system the impact history of the
inner solar system and as I've already
mentioned it's a guide particularly to
the early history of the earth and Mars
and we had this delineation of the
potential when a resource potential that
I mentioned and that's not too shabby
for a program program that was clearly
not designed with the science of the
moon in mind we we got a hell of a lot
out of it and and unfortunately that is
not even fully recognized within the
scientific community today and so ladies
and gentlemen let me thank you very much
for your attention thank you for your
attention to our colleagues here it's
been a great ride and I hope it's not
over yet
thank you very much
and finally chris-craft a legend in his
time and I'll just also remind you of
one piece of advice that you gave us as
new young astronauts and that was you of
course had had gone already through the
Apollo program and and had now taken the
space shuttle program to the point of
first flight and and you reminded us
that the first flight of a new vehicle
is a very unique time and that we should
pay very close attention because we were
probably not going to get to see another
one again I hope we see another one
while we're still around but again I
thank you for your advice and for all
the support that you've given us over
the years thank you thank you for having
me it's a pleasure and an honor to be
here at MIT I came to honor the people
the knowledge and the ingenuity of this
great institution without it we would
never have gone to the moon as a matter
of fact we wouldn't have done many
things in space the people that start
Draper developed here when he built the
I am use and the computers were
fundamental to the advancement of
everything we did in this country
particularly in space flight so when you
think about MIT you think about stark
Draper you think about Davy ho AG Malcom
Johnston dick batten and really a whole
host of other people that reside in this
part of the world certainly the work
they did on all of those elements I just
mentioned were fundamental to going to
the moon and going into space I was
going to say that when I stood up that
I'd rather just stand up here and tell
stories I'll tell one because it
reminded me a lot of some of us
long-winded people
when uh when I went to New York City to
a ticker-tape parade for the last flight
of mercury we were in the Astra hotel
and up on the Dyess was a number of
people including my boss what William
sitting next to Herbert Hoover he had
been brought down out of the Attic
probably where he was where he lived in
the hotel and I noticed he looked over
at Walt and said a few words to him and
I asked Walt after it was over and he
said What did he say and he said he
asked me who was speaking next and he
said I told him a Jim Webb he said he
reached over and turned off as his
earphones and said let let me know wake
me up when he finishes so if you want to
go to sleep go ahead it's okay with me a
gel I wanted to tell you there was a
solder ball still left in Apollo 14
and these people here at MIT figured out
how to with that small amount of
erasable memory and and they're able
bill cheated to bone it up from the
ground by command to wire around that
switch and we were able to finish the
flight because of them so you weren't
perfect when I used to go to Grumman
they used to call me the wire cutter
because they would have all these
problems with the caution and warning
system and I'd say just cut the damn
wire usually work to also hammer worked
on on the Skylab I said hit it with a
hammer and it well I wanted to say that
also when I stood up was that I'm last
and that's normal for me because as an
operator I was always stuck with
everything that anybody didn't know what
the hell to do with and we still want to
launch it so I'm used to used to that
people ask me what is the difference
between flight control and the people at
Cape Canaveral and I said well they put
it on the pad they check it all out when
they find out it doesn't work to go get
another piece put it in there and fix it
and then you start to countdown again
when you give it to me that damn thing
is there I can't change it I can't fix
it I've got to fly what you gave me
remember that that's a the crux of
flight control you have to fly what you
got no time to stop and fix it not
entirely true today and in the Space Lab
in the early years of spaceflight before
we really got started in this thing you
have to remember that we were struggling
with the ability of the human being we
did not know that man could do a job at
zero gravity
95 to 98% of the medical community in
this country thought that the eyeballs
would pop out at zero-g that the man
would swallow his tongue and I heard
things like 24-hour ulcers where the man
was going to bleed to death on the pad
and we had to be able to get to him in
three minutes getting to a spacecraft in
three minutes when you don't have any
allow any people on the pad is a tough
order
I had one doctor that proposed that we
get a helicopter put a key in the Marmon
clamp on mercury so that he could undo
the clamp go in there with a helicopter
and get the astronaut oh I never thought
that was a very good idea
i as you recall on the first redstone
abort first air instrument flight we had
an animal flight and the chimpanzee was
sitting on the pad and we launched him
and before we could get rid of the
escape tower the engine shut down early
and it threw the spacecraft and the
chimpanzee off into space with a 17 g
kick in the Fanny and that was quite a
jolt to our instruments and the
spacecraft and chimpanzee and every
doctor in this country wanted us to take
45 chimpanzees to the Johnsville
centrifuge and test them to destruction
meanwhile mr. Gagarin flew and so they
backed off of that and said well we
guessed man can survive in space so that
was a shock to us to have Gagarin fly
before we did and it was because we had
made some errors in the Redstone launch
but then on May the 5th Alan Shepard
flew for his first 15-minute flight and
six minutes of zero gravity now the
world response to those two flights
was phenomenal the Russians when Gagarin
flew put it on page 37 of their
newspaper the next day it was on
headlines in the paper because the rest
of the world went bananas
as you recall well maybe you know maybe
something hyuna's audience don't recall
that the rest of the world did go
bananas and it was at that point in time
as mr. Sorenson said that mr. Kennedy
had been thinking about this and
challenged the United States to go to
the moon I remember that day very
clearly I thought he had lost his mind
here I was at Cape Canaveral had not
launched John Glenn yet in space did not
know how to do orbit determination from
the ground with radar but suddenly being
in charge of flight operations as well
as being the flight director at that
point I now had to come up with the
orbital mechanics of how you go back and
forth to the moon and that was to me a
hell of a challenge so at that point I
realized and still do today that
spaceflight is inexorably entwined with
politics just remember that as we try to
make some decisions and what we're going
to do in the next program and what we're
going to do and what mr. Augustine is
going to come up with that he wants mr.
Obama to sign to check for it is in fine
in fact even Christopher Columbus my
name SiC found that out back in 1400s
that he had to get Isabel to cash her
chips before he could go explore the
West and that's the way it's probably
going to be forever we have to do the
political along with the engineering I
think we can figure out the engineering
and I want I point out to you again that
just because I remember
right that when mr. Kennedy said we're
going to go to the moon in this decade
it it had us all going back to read
Jules Verne and find out about direct
descent Earth orbit ways of doing it and
some guy named white white at the
Langley Research Center and his boss
Hewitt Phillips invented lunar orbit
rendezvous mr. Hubble was the salesman
but there's where the beauty of great
engineering comes from it was that time
period when we started thinking about
how we were going to land something on
the moon and Bob gurus and I riding back
and forth in a Gulfstream and he said
can you imagine that we're going to put
take the redstone rocket if you can
imagine that what the register on rocket
remember that what that looked like was
a capsule on top and that's what we're
gonna land on the moon when we do direct
descent that didn't make a lot of sense
and that's when all these young men came
over the idea of a bug of separating it
taking only hit down to the surface and
that bug at that point in time only
included one person but we figured he
better have a playmate to go to the
lunar surface because he might fall down
like a turtle and not be able to get
back up in that spacesuit
I don't know whether Neal remembers that
or not but I'm sure he was glad to have
buzzed along to get him if he yelled if
he fell down the story I could tell
about the about the television system on
on Apollo it also be interesting I'll
tell you that later because you don't
want to see here all day and mr. my
stories
now what this then led mr. mr. Kennedy's
decision was it led to the Germany
program which we quickly put together
because we didn't know how to maneuver
in space we didn't know how to
rendezvous in space we didn't know how
to dock in space we didn't know how to
do evey a we didn't know how to spend
four
teen days in space and we didn't know
how to do a guided reentry from space
and Germany did all of that for us
and we did that whole program in two
years with twelve flights like to remind
the people working on constellation
today I won't go into a lot of details a
lot of people several people have
mentioned the tragedy on the fire of the
fire on the pad there was a horrible day
for me horrible day for everybody that
had anything to do with spaceflight
those those noises still ringing in my
ear but I want to say that without the
fire on a pad we would never have done
Apollo 11 in fact I'm not sure we would
have ever done Apollo because it was
just a lousy spacecraft we didn't know a
lot we were running too fast
two weeks after the fire we had a
meeting with George Lowe and put down
125 different things we wanted to do
differently on the spacecraft and we did
every one of them before we flew again
in the summer of 1968 when we conceived
Apollo 8 everybody talks about the
Saturn 5 I want you to know that the
second Saturn flight Saturn 5 flight had
a major problem in all three stages a
pogo in the first stage a resonance in
the second stage and the thought state
that the third stage would not refire
because it froze in space and yet when
we decided to go to the moon on Apollo 8
we used the Saturn 5 the next time to
send man there I'll remind you of that
also because it took one hell of a lot
of guts
to make up your mind you're going to do
that and we need some of that today we
need some guts if we're going to do a
space program we are not going to do it
without having that kind of thought
process in our brains the flight of
Apollo 11 was indeed a tremendous event
fantastic experience one in which was
there was so much exhilaration that you
wee hard to cut it except with a knife
it was a time of celebration for all of
us but it was a time when we recognized
that there were many legacies of Apollo
and that's where I'll try to close Paolo
told us we could do anything we set our
mind to in this country anything if we
know what we want to do where we want to
go and have the commitment to get it
done there are many people that say
today if we can go to the moon and bring
man safely back in ten years as we did
in Apollo we can do anything the problem
I have with that is they do not
recognize what that means we need a
commitment a dedication of everybody in
this country who matters to make those
kinds of things happen that's what we
had for Apollo every lady old lady in
the country that did wire bundles for us
in the vehicle and on the harnesses
realized how important it was that what
they were doing and how important that
was to the future that man's life
depended on what they did that's just a
part a small element but that's the kind
of feeling you had to have throughout
the country from the president down Vice
President Johnson the Congress everybody
that
trying to check the OMB OMB OMB those
are the guys that saw him to check today
we have to have a commitment to do
whatever this country sets out to do
that's the legacy of Apollo so thank God
let's get on with whatever the next
program is thank you
you